this video is brought to you by
curiositystream
sign up today at curiositystream.com
real science to get both curiosity
stream and nebula for just 11 59 for the
entire year
[Music]
in every ocean in the world from coastal
shorelines to the tropics to the poles
to the endless deep expanses
live the most widespread creature in the
world after humans
through the centuries it's been given
many names blackfish grampus whale
killer and while the seas are full of
creatures vying for their place on the
food chain the orca is unequivocally on
top
their latin name orsonous orca is
derived from the name orcus god of the
underworld and champion of death an apt
reference to their fierce hunting
reputation
they are the ultimate apex predator of
the ocean hunting everything from fish
to seals and sea lions to humpback
whales and even great white sharks
and it's not just what they hunt but how
they do it that sets them apart from
every other animal
in the case of great white sharks orcas
will chase them down in packs and ram
into their sides
the blow stuns the shark allowing the
orca to flip the great white over and
hold it upside down which paralyzes and
drowns it and the orcas don't simply eat
the shark either
they carefully extract and consume just
the livers with an almost surgical
precision
great whites are so terrified of orcas
that if a shark escapes an encounter
with an orca the shark will immediately
flee their hunting ground and stay away
for up to a year
packs of antarctic orcas use the cunning
tactic of working together to make waves
to wash seals off floating ice
other groups swim in circles around
schools of fish blowing bubbles while
slapping their tails on the water to
corral the fish to the surface where
they can be annihilated in mass
they have been seen to coordinate hunts
between as many as 50 individuals and
are constantly innovating new often
terrifying hunting methods
hunting strategies like this have
entranced scientists for years because
of their apparent military precision how
are orcas able to communicate and
coordinate such complicated concepts how
do they come up with so many new ideas
and implement them so effectively
while many of these answers are still
being uncovered research is starting to
get inside the minds of orcas revealing
just how powerful the orca collective
can be
[Music]
though often called killer whales orcas
are more specifically in the dolphin
family of which it is the largest member
today they are the apex predator of the
sea
but their evolutionary story didn't
always take place there fifty million
years ago this land-dwelling wolf-sized
creature called the pachycitis lived
along the edges of a shallow ocean where
it ate fish and other small sea
creatures
over the next eight million years some
of its lineage slowly ventured more and
more to sea exploiting more ocean
resources and trading its legs for
flippers
remnants of today's whales land dwelling
origins can be found in their front
flippers
where there are arm wrist and finger
bones and in their vestigial pelvic bone
a bone which serves no purpose today but
is simply a leftover from when they had
hind legs
today orcas are one of the most
recognizable animals in the ocean with
their distinct black and white coloring
and immense size
males can reach over 9 meters long and
weigh up to 10 metric tons about the
size and weight of a school bus and they
can propel their huge bodies through the
water at a ridiculously fast clip and
orca's body is cylindrical and tapers at
each end to form a hydrodynamic shape
this shape along with the orca's size
and strength
makes it the second fastest marine
mammal reaching speeds of up to 35
kilometers an hour
at times they've been seen leaping 15
feet into the air and you would not want
to be their target
their bite force exceeds 131 megapascals
for reference a great white spite force
is estimated to be only 27.5 megapascals
acting alone their size speed and
terrifying jaws would probably be enough
to put them at the top of the food chain
in the ocean but they don't operate
alone orcas almost always work together
in deadly pods
the pod is a family unit based on the
maternal group a typical mature line
consists of an older female or matriarch
and her male and female descendants
these groups work together in sometimes
perfect synchrony with a precision that
is hard for scientists to wrap their
heads around
likely the basis for this teamwork is a
refined and complex form of
communication
we don't know yet exactly what they're
saying but researchers believe that
their huge repertoire of sounds calls
and whistles communicate complex
messages to one another
in the 1970s scientists started to
record and analyze the numerous sounds
orcas make beneath the waves in an
attempt to gain insight into their
mysterious underwater language
first they heard many clicks called
click trains
these are the sounds the whales use for
echolocation as they look for food
sources and map their underwater
environment with sound
to create a click train the orca takes a
breath and pressure from streams of air
bubbles move up the airway from the
lungs this causes two flaps called the
phonic lips to slap together the
clicking vibrations are then transferred
to their bulbous forehead aptly called
their melon the melon is an organ made
up of specialized fats that help sound
propagate the clicks are organized into
a beam as it travels through the melon
the sound is then emitted outwards as a
series of high frequency clicks and
spread through the water like a
flashlight beam
each click lasts less than one
millisecond with frequencies ranging
from 20 to 60 kilohertz and with levels
recorded over 220
decibels
decibels underwater are measured
slightly differently than in air making
this seem extreme but it is still
insanely loud if the sound waves hit an
object some sound waves bounce back to
the whale in the form of an echo
specialized fatty tissues in the jaw
area pick up the sound and auditory
nerves conduct it to the middle ear and
brain where it creates a picture of the
environment for the orca
echolocation allows killer whales to
detect fish at distances of up to 500
feet much further away than they could
see in the dark murky water
they can even differentiate acoustic
signatures of different swim bladders of
different species of fish to ensure they
get their favorite kind killer whales in
the north pacific for example prefer to
eat almost exclusively chinook salmon
whose range exceeds 15 000 square miles
this huge area is occupied by hundreds
of other species of fish including five
other species of salmon whose
populations are often far more abundant
than the chinook salmon but yet the
orcas can pinpoint and hunt down just
the fish they want
their echolocation is astoundingly
precise
next researchers focused in on a
different sound the orcas were making
whistles
whistles are high pitched show a high
degree of directionality and are highly
modulated and as a result they don't
carry far underwater whistles are narrow
band tones with no or few harmonic
components at frequencies typically
between 1.5 and 18 kilohertz and
durations up to 12 seconds
they can even extend into the ultrasonic
range with frequencies ranging up to 75
kilohertz in some populations
and because they don't travel far in
water scientists realized that these are
the sounds the whales make when they
want to have close range private
communication with their pod mates which
likely helps them coordinate certain
attacks in relative secrecy
and then there are the orca calls as
loud as jet engines that echo over many
miles in the ocean
these pulsed calls are the most common
vocalization of killer whales
they show sudden and pattern shifts in
frequency based on the pulse repetition
rate which is usually between 0.25 and 2
kilohertz
and what's surprising is that these
vocalizations are not genetically
predetermined they are learned
when a calf is born its first
vocalizations are loud high-pitched
screams that bear no resemblance to the
adults calls
but eventually cavs learn which calls to
make and under what circumstances
scientists however have not yet learned
the exact meaning of the oracle language
but know that it's important for
coordinating hunts
when orcas are working together during a
herring hunt for example the sound
underwater is off the charts there are
clicks whistles calls sometimes with
harmonic tones and tons of undulation
because of its learned nature and
complexity
scientists believe that there is
potential for communication of complex
specific information in calls a true
language being spoken
researchers are processing hundreds of
hours of audio data from tagged animals
in an attempt to correlate the sounds to
certain behaviors to understand how
exactly they communicate their hunts
using artificial intelligence scientists
hope to one day be able to literally
translate whale language into ours
perhaps even allowing us to converse
with another species
recently an ai was developed that can
translate one human language to another
without help from a rosetta stone or key
taking this one step further to decipher
whale language may not be that
far-fetched
researchers are already working on
training their ai to identify call types
find possible sub units and detect
recurring communication patterns
this correlated with observed behavioral
patterns may one day decode the orcas
language
but beyond giving hunting signals orca
language serves another purpose
language is the basis for every
orchapod's group identity
an identity so solid that orca pods in a
sense have cultures as rich and varied
as our own
and it is this culture this group
identity that sets them apart as the
most effective predators in the ocean
though many pods of orca often live in
close proximity to each other they can
lead wildly different lives
a type of pod called resident pods live
in relatively predictable locations
largely around coastlines such as the
well-studied northern and southern
residents off the coast of british
columbia
these are the most common types of orca
and many pods of resident orcas can live
near each other not exactly living and
working together but on occasion
interacting these pods typically have an
average of 14 members but up to as many
as 50 and they typically hunt fish but
then there's another type of orca called
transient orcas that are far more rare
these elusive and mysterious whales
occur sporadically in unpredictable
locations often staying submerged for
much longer than residents hugging the
shore but staying out of sight
these renegade orcas travel huge
distances over their lives with some
pods of transients known to travel
between alaska and california
transient pods are much smaller
averaging around three members and they
typically hunt marine mammals like sea
lions
transient orcas do not interact with
resident orcas it was clear to
researchers from the beginning that
orcas opted to live in these groups
but just how distinct these pods were
from one another wasn't revealed until
the 1980s
when researchers for the first time
began to listen more closely to the
different orca conversations happening
under the waves
and what they found was that each pod
has its own collection of calls
referred to as their very own dialect
one group of resident orcas for example
relied on calls that begin with a low
pulse rate burst followed by a
simultaneous narrow band tone which
begins at a frequency of three to five
kilohertz and then increases to over
eight kilohertz
another group of resident orcas uses a
different type of call altogether a low
frequency gradually rising tone
followed by a lower pitch pulse which is
then followed by a sudden shift to a
high frequency tone and ending with
another low pitched burst
resident orcas can have dozens of
identifiable calls like this
each completely unique to their specific
pod
and the difference in calls between
resident and transient orcas even in the
same area gets even bigger
transient whales overall are very quiet
compared to the residents when they are
foraging they're usually completely
silent not even using echolocation which
is heard in abundance in resident pods
but all transient orcas studied in the
pacific northwest shared one type of
distinct call usually used while
foraging and even then they did so
rarely
a long quiet low frequency call
the different orca dialects often go
unchanged within a pod for decades
indicating that they're likely an
essential way to maintain group identity
and this group identity is the key to
their unrivaled success
a cultural species behaves differently
than a species where everything is
determined genetically
with each orca dialect comes a suite of
wildly varied behaviors from group to
group each with particular traditions
that allow them to carve out a
specialized niche hunting a particular
target with a sophisticated sometimes
terrifying strategy
the killer whales off the coast of
argentina have perhaps the most
startling tradition of all
it was first observed in 1985 and
scientists could almost not believe what
they were seeing when the tide is high
and the sea is calm the orcas snag sea
lions directly from the shore by
intentionally beaching themselves
like a terrifying tsunami the orca surfs
on an advancing wave until it's close
enough to grab the unsuspecting sea lion
from the tumultuous surf zone
sea lions are notoriously clumsy on land
and during the transition from swimming
to walking in shallow and turbulent
water so by the time they notice death
itself approaching it's usually too late
to get away
once grounded the whale arches its body
with its head and tail lifted and rocks
sideways
this motion orients it parallel to the
beach and a subsequent wave helps to
lift it off the bottom
the whale can then swim back into deeper
water carrying the prey in its mouth
where it will eat it or share it with
its pod
this intentional beaching technique is a
tricky maneuver it's not easy for the
orcas to synchronize their movements
with the waves coming in and then back
out and if they miscalculate they risk
getting actually stuck which can prove
to be deadly
there are 30 orcas that live along this
stretch of coastline but only 13 orcas
have mastered the stranding technique to
get to this level of mastery they have
gone through years of rigorous teaching
and training
young orcas can be seen with older
adults practicing again and again
beaching themselves repeatedly but not
yet trying to catch any prey
sometimes the older orca introduces a
prop like seaweed to enrich the training
it's always females who teach the young
orcas and they do so with remarkable
care and patience
some young whales never make it through
the training the feeling of going
aground and the feeling of their entire
body weight out of the water freaks them
out enough to never try again only a few
ever get the hang of it the young orca's
first attempt to catch live seals might
not happen for years and when it does
they still need the assistance of an
adult to return to the water with their
prey
this shows that learning hunting
techniques needs a high degree of skill
and requires high parental investment to
reduce the associated risk
and though difficult time consuming and
dangerous social transfer of skills like
this through apprenticeship is one of
the key reasons orcas are so highly
adaptable and thus such formidable
predators throughout the entire world
the culture and groups of orcas is so
profound that scientists even believe
that orcas are the only non-human
organism whose evolution is driven by it
just as some humans have evolved to
tolerate lactose for example as cow milk
became increasingly introduced to our
diets orcas too are evolving due to
their choices and traditions
transient orcas are even so distinct
from resident orcas that scientists
believe it's a matter of time until they
become their own species
not because geography separated them but
because culture did
but there's one more key ingredient
without which none of the orca's complex
culture would be possible the orca's
giant brain and incredible intelligence
orcas have the second biggest brain in
the animal kingdom after sperm whales it
weighs in at a whopping 5.4 to 6.8
kilograms
but exactly how brain size translates to
intelligence is not straightforward
scientists have found that while
absolute size is important its size
relative to the body is more so
the larger the brain is relative to the
body the more brain weight might be
available for more complex cognitive
tasks
one measure called the encephalization
quotient or eq tries to measure this
ratio and is used to convey how small or
large a species brain is compared to
other species with a similar body size
and orcas are near the top of the list
humans have the largest with an eq of
about seven
bottlenose dolphins are next with an eq
of around four and next are the orcas at
about 2.5
but beyond this impressive brain to body
ratio compared to other mammalian brains
the aurica brain is in many respects
highly unusual because it has extremely
pronounced wrinkling and folding in the
cerebral cortex
this wrinkling is called gyrification
gyrification increases the amount of
total cortical nerve tissue that
processes information making brains with
more wrinkles and folds able to handle
more data and process it faster
cetaceans the toothed whales and
dolphins have significantly higher
gyrification compared to land mammals
the gyroencephale index for humans is
2.2 for bottlenose dolphins it's 5.6 and
for orcas it's 5.7 the most gyrified
brain in the world
yet perhaps the most fascinating
structure in an orca's brain is its
extremely developed insular cortex
the insula is involved in consciousness
and the regulation of emotions like
compassion empathy interpersonal
experience and self-awareness
this means the orca may be emotionally
intelligent in the same way we are
aware of the feelings of others and
aware of its own existence and this may
be the ultimate measure of consciousness
in the animal kingdom
in 2001 researchers put orcas to the
test
a test to gauge if orcas do indeed have
a sense of self by determining whether
they can recognize their own reflection
in a mirror as an image of itself
this was done surreptitiously by marking
the black part of its rostrum with white
ointment and the white part with a dark
green ointment and observing whether the
animal reacts in a manner consistent
with it being aware that the dye is
located on its own body
such behavior might include turning and
adjusting the body in order to better
view the marking in the mirror and the
orcas in the study not only noticed the
markings but seemed to be completely
fixated on them they had spent time in
front of mirrors before but with the
markings seemed to not be able to look
away
they blew bubbles at their reflection
bobbed their head and stuck their tongue
out and all these behaviors were
unusually frequent and lasted longer
than at any time before the markings
were placed
while this is not necessarily a sign of
consciousness as we know it it is not
unreasonable to think that the orca mind
works a lot like ours and that they are
capable of high level thinking and
feeling and can perceive the vast
complexity of the world they live in
a highly intelligent dominant social
species where the young are taught
difficult lessons over many years and
where family takes care of each other
it's hard to not see a reflection of
ourselves in them even though we
diverged from the orcas many millions of
years ago they may be our closest
counterpart in the way we both
experience this world
the more we observe the oracle world the
more the incredible complexity of their
lives becomes clear to us
and at every turn researchers seem to be
discovering an orca behavior even more
mind-blowing than the last recently
another orca behavior started to be
revealed and was also caught on film
orcas are notorious for working together
with other orcas
but now they've been caught on camera
not just working with their own pods but
with a completely different species the
humpback whale what is sometimes their
prey humpback whales are now acting as
their partner in some areas as they help
each other in hunting shoals of herring
it's a behavior that has to be seen to
be believed and to see it in action you
should watch the orca's first humpback
episode of sea hunters on curiosity
stream this is a brand new six part
series that covers unexpected survival
techniques of the ocean's predators with
some of the most groundbreaking footage
of these behaviors that's ever been
captured other episodes include the
unexpected conflict between sea lions
and hyenas and the cooperation between
dolphins and gannets and detailed
coverage of the orca stranding method as
they snatch sea lions from the shore
this is one of many incredible series on
curiosity stream alone curiosity stream
is a fantastic educational streaming
platform but now curiositystream has
partnered with us to offer an even
better package by signing up to
curiositystream you now also get a
subscription to nebula nebula is a
streaming platform made by me and
several other educational youtube
content creators
it's a place where we can upload our
content ad free and a place where we can
experiment with new original videos we
have so much new exclusive content
planned for nebula in the new year like
a real science series on human evolution
and real engineering's new series the
battle of britain
and right now the bundle deal is at a
hugely discounted holiday price for just
11 59 you get access to both curiosity
stream and nebula for the entire year
that's 42 off the usual price and means
you're getting both services for less
than a dollar per month
it could be a great last minute
christmas gift for your friends and
family that you don't have to stand in
line at the post office for an hour to
ship
signing up is also the single best way
you can support this channel it helps us
to keep growing and helps us to bring
you more and more new content
so go to
curiositystream.com real science to get
in on this incredible deal and if you're
looking for something else to watch
right now you can watch our previous
video about the complex reality of
lab-grown meat or watch real
engineering's latest video about the
insane engineering of the james webb
telescope
[Music]